comme nous besoin d'entendre
c'est là dessus
à 20h50
alors michel il est génial il a été
composé par jean pierre bouteyre et jean
claude petit mais voilà toujours
jean-claude petit fou jours alors dans
cette émission michel tu interview les
autres donc on s'est dit avec catherine
barma
c'est quand même con que lui on
l'interview pas donc on a décidé de
l'inviter ce soir c'est la première fois
alors ta carrière michel se déroule sur
plusieurs générations sur plusieurs
décennies sur quatre décennies
exactement sur plusieurs septennat voilà
et oui et tu dis je suis le plus jeune
des ancien et le plus ancien des jeunes
c'est qu'en fait tu as connu l'époque de
l'après guerre c'était la télévision là
la fin la tesi en noir et blanc doux et
tu es toujours là en dehors en 2004 tu
dis l'histoire de la télé c'est
l'histoire de ma vie
et oui parce que moi je suis rentré en
1964 par hasard j'y suis encore qui est
miraculeux est souvent dit mais comment
tu fais pour être encore là et pourquoi
mais je dis parce que lorsque j'ai
commencé dans ce métier j'ai voulu le
faire toute ma vie mon père était
médecin il n'a pas fait médecine pour le
faire pendant cinq ans quand tu as
commencé c'était cognacq-jay c'était si
tron qui était l'homme à tout faire de
zitrone et il travaillait avec zitrone
de 7 heures du matin à minuit
je bossais aux sports et puis je faisais
un petit peu des heures supplémentaires
avec lui je lui ai conduit sa voiture
souvent je le faisais en trouvant dans
le détail mitis ici non souvent je
faisais même répété les casaques du
caire soir il valait contre-allée de
l'avenue bosquet et sa femme donnait un
torchon il avait hâte au pluralisme et à
droite de la voiture
il mangeait ce qu'avaient préparé sa
femme qui a été débordé moi je lisais
casaque verte au khroub et les gens nous
voyaient hébété avec la beuh et de la
voiture ils vérifient moi j'étais
inconnu zitrone est une immense star
qu'on n'imagine pas il y avait deux
goals gabin morgant et et lui dans les
sondages
et puis zitrone répondent aux
téléspectateurs dans la rue g et ceci
trône il leur disait n'approchez pas je
vous interdis je suis une personne
privée je vous interdis ne me reconnaît
il et j'étais terrifié il était très
méchant dans zitrone il ils étaient
impitoyables en dehors de son travail il
ne voulait pas qu'on emmerde dans sa vie
personnelle sauf que lorsqu'on fait un
métier public
vous en savez tous les quelque chose il
faudra combien les rongeurs n'avions
dans un train ce qui te dit je vous aime
beaucoup
c'était quelqu'un d'extrêmement dur etc
avaient plutôt tendance à caresser les
ministres en place dans le
voilà ce qui déplaisait de terriblement
à claude darget voilà alors il y avait
claude darget zitrone allait remplacer
claude dargent et claude darget tu me
racontes et lui lui lui offrait chaque
carnet du cirage
oui et un gilet rayé de nestor et c'est
moi qui vais l'acheter en plus mouais
c'est à dire que j'ai détesté zitrone
ils le détestent tellement qu'ils
avaient dressé son chien pour qu'il
aille pisser sur l'apport de cinq mois
qui aimait déjà beaucoup les chiens j'ai
beaucoup contribué au dressage et un
jour l'arsouille s'appeler l'ares soul
le chien il est descendu son plateau du
journal et on a vu se diriger alors que
jointe est commencée et pisser sur les
visites seront en direct pendant le
journal
j'aurais tellement voulu que le
caméraman des saints peut pouvoir léon
zitrone secouer sa jambe pendant que le
chien de l'arjel et lui a reçu pas tant
ils se détestaient cordialement
il avait un grand talent tous les deux
oui tu te souviennes d'arz et j'ai bien
sûr je vois comme un vieux vraiment
cette solitaire
oui d'un bon vin l'amie des animaux
et c'est vrai frédéric on cite un ami
des animaux
oui il commentait le tennis et c'est un
mec formidable
alors ce qui est incroyable c'est que
toi tu as fait grève en 68 j'étais viré
par de nouveaux n'ai pas supporté que sa
télévision se mettant en grève
donc il a aligné tous les mecs connu
zitrone large échappa de coude et a tiré
en l'air à moi j'étais le dernier joueur
25 26 ans j'ai traqué aussi parce que je
présente mes à l'émission de variétés de
michal ardo et j'ai cru que j'allais
disparaître parce que imaginer je sais
pas moi de la rue où arthur ou nagui ou
la nouvelle génération qui est déjà en
place et qu'on vire au bout de six ou
sept ans ouais alors qu'on est en pleine
ascension
j'ai cru que je m'en remettrai jamais
mais ça m'a était extrêmement utile car
j'ai découvert vraiment qu'on n'était
pas des stars ouais
à l'époque quand on s'est fait lourder
on était persuadé que que la france
descend vers la rue pour nous sauver
itron de penser qu'il y aura une grève
vrai on veut zitrone ya trois mois on
m'appelait maurice brugger au bout de
six mois alors j'étais souvent dit
michel que ma femme tu appelles
terminator béatrice elle dit est dit
drucker c'est terminator parce que
terminator celui qui est toujours vivant
à la fin du film si c'est terminator
mais c'est un terminator qu'a failli
tomber plusieurs fois ouais parce que ce
qu'on ne sait pas c'est que j'ai pris
quelques gamelles mai 68 c'était très
douloureux mais j'ai failli sauter
souvent il ya il ya eu l'histoire moi je
me souviens parce que j'étais j'étais là
c'est l'époque de philippe guillôme à
mai mois et maintenant il m'a fait un
truc incroyable j'étais là depuis huit
ans je faisais champs-elysées il vient
déjeuner chez moi quand on est en fin de
contrat la télévision chez moi quand ça
se passe dans le disque en général mais
maintenant dans l'usiné pareil oui la
cuisine avec le grand patron alors si
c'est chez toi tu dis tiens il vient
chez moi c'est bien ma femme est jamais
la semaine jamais de ça on est en tête à
tête et au moment elle ouvre la porte
pour servir le café et longtemps le
patron de l'époque me dire juste ce bout
de phrase
de toute façon michel la télévision de
demain ne passera pas par vous cros donc
champs elysées champs-elysées c'est fini
moi je prends ça sur la tête j'avais 43
44 ans elle referme l'accord
je le raccompagne à l'ascenseur et là il
m'a somme pour le compte il me dit
écoute et j'écoutais donc je vais aller
sur l'a5 puisque on me demande d'aller
sur l'a5 désespérément ou sur la une de
chez bouygues et je voudrais rester dans
service public parce que c'est ma
famille j'y suis quand même depuis très
longtemps et là il m'a dit non non vous
n'avez pas compris
vous allez continuer champs elysées
pendant un an mais vous allez former un
jeu de rôle
ah oui c'est à dire qu'il a refermé la
soeur à temps et je suis rentré chez moi
un [ __ ] ma femme m'a dit t'es pas le
bienvenu en âge et je partais le soir
avec depardieu pour faire argent elysées
à new york et je m'en souviendrai toute
ma vie je raconte ça il dit thiat
profile un coup de boule de sa voisine
on le fait bien en vie il me jean et
tennis de finesse et décrocher le
téléphone
j'ai appelé dominique cantien j'étudie à
fond si oui que c'est d'accord lundi
chez déjeuner et 24 ans après c'est sûr
tu es là voilà pour faire stars 90 mais
mais mais mais c'est vrai que bon je
n'étais pas de gaieté de coeur
l'émission était difficile
c'est une mission qui était un lundi
soir une émission de variétés avait
beaucoup de filles puissent y avait la
cinquième édition d'arrêter le mercredi
il y en avait une de vendredi et le
samedi
j'ai tenu quatre ans mais quatre ans
assez confortable parce que rendons-leur
cette justice j'avais été engagées
barbry le lay mougeotte ont été
extrêmement réglo j'ai fait ce que j'ai
voulu mais il était temps que je parte
alors tu aurais fait quoi imagine que
bon bilan ne veut plus de toi imagine
que s'enrichir à sur tf1 mais tu aurais
fait quoi j'aurais fait de la radio sans
doute
et puis j'aurais fait ce que tu as fais
toi pendant trois ou quatre ans j'aurais
attendu
oui que l'argent que la chambre par bien
sûr mais j'ai fait sonner 1 alors qu'ils
quand même un obsédé de la durée a pris
ce qui t'intéresse c'est dur et
d'ailleurs avec ta femme ça durera vous
êtes marié avec dennis aval depuis 1973
oui de l'export jackass est énorme là ça
fait quand même pas mal d'années alors
elle avant d'être mariée avec toi elle
était mariée avec maurice jarre mais
père de jean-michel jarre qui est
couvert d'oscars et le papa de stéphanie
voilà c'est un peu comme ma fille est
donc toi quand tu as épousé dany non
seulement il fallait qu'il fasse aussi
bien que son premier mari qui était
couvert d'oscars
mais en plus que tu fasse plaisir à ta
mère qui trouvait quand même que bon
animateur tv c'est quand même pas génial
donc toute ta vie tu as eu cette
pression quand même un animateur télé ma
mère
ça nulle puisque elle avait 3 bible
ouais chancel télérama le monde ouais
elle mérite by nolin et me disait
toujours et me disait toujours
c'est dommage parce que pour une fois à
télérama enfin consacré sa une
ils ont mis 35 ans elle n'était pas là
pour le voir enfin bref et quand
j'arrivais le soir le dimanche
enjouaillez télérama le monde et
collectionner tous les éditoriaux de
jean daniel hamelin il dit maryse du
business et grandpré cible elle
considérait que le grand échiquier
c'était beaucoup mieux champs elysées et
que rostropovitch était bien mathieu
c'est moins bien ouais alors dit moi
dani et toi on vous voit jamais ensemble
très peu comment ça se fait parce que
moi j'ai la chance d'avoir une épouse
qui a pas ou il exister car elle a
existé bien avant moi ouais elle a un
univers elle dans lequel est très
heureuse on vit beaucoup en province
elle a une passion c'est pas un stylisme
1008p lui qui a 50 ça il sait ce que
c'est que ça va
25 chiens et et puis en réalité elle
fait partie d'une catégorie de femmes
assez rare mais je suis sûr que béatrice
ardisson me comprendra qui est assez
fier du succès de son maître c'est à
dire quand je pars le matin depuis 30
ans j'ai l'impression qu'on me dit allez
prendre un cartable n'oublie pas ton 4h
et ramène moi de bonnes notes
elle est assez contente de cette somme
est qu'est ce qui est assez rare et si
vous avez un compte joint ça joue aussi
elle voit bien quels défauts ni en
acquérant seraient les premiers à leur
est alors il a pas il a raison de dire
ça quand je dis rencontré j'étais fauché
qui était fauché j'habitais chez eux
disent pas possible donc j'ai beaucoup
travaillé également ya rien de plus un
sursis habiter chez sa femme quand quand
et les économiquement faibles des deux
ouais c'est pas cette arrivée sans mal
dis donc j'ai beaucoup bossé pour ça
jacques vous avez un compte joint avec
françoise baud non non non non non pas
le même pas le lit mais toi alors on
apprendre dans le livre son livre génial
on apprend dans le bouquin qu'en fait
lui c'est vraiment c'est vraiment pas la
fourmi a ce moment la cigale l'ua et la
wii dilapide il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
points communs entre françoise hardy et
jacques et derniers mois c'est que aucun
des deux ne bouffent l'oxygène de l'eau
près et qu'on respecte chacun nos
passions et nos pelles ou pâté nos amis
alors dany saval escale aime la natation
non est ce qu'elle aime le vélo rien du
tout est ce qu'elle aime l'hélico non
est-ce qu'elle supporte la nervosité
thon entier fait elle est assez contente
quand je me casse le matin quand je
reviens tard le soir
ouais quand je suis assez fatiguant mon
entourage je suis comme toi je bosse
tout le temps elle dit quoi quand tu
t'es les fans en dînant par exemple
alors il fait plus attention mais là où
elle me regarde bizarrement c'est quand
justement on doit le réfrigérateur est
bien la même place depuis 30 ans elle
est d'accord alors la télévision évolue
et évidemment depuis 40 ans en vingt ans
par exemple on est passé du mieux disant
culturel de françois léotard quand il a
été question de vendre tf1 à willis de
la culture de l'époque voilà donc le
mieux disant culturel
tf1 est aujourd'hui c'est patrick le lay
qui dit nous vendons du temps de cerveau
disponible à coca cola moi j'ai passé
quatre ans sur tf1
et c'était la règle était déjà limpide
quand je veux dire la grande différence
entre une chaîne commerciale service
public c'est qu'ils peuvent pas d'états
d'âme
il faut que la pub rang alors de là à
dire qu'une émission est bonne parce
qu'elle a fait prendre 5 % de parts de
marché 6 millions elle est mauvaise il a
fait moins alors là ça va ce débat parce
que si on va jusqu'au bout on peut
penser que thaksin est un meilleur film
que le pianiste sur la liste schindler
et n'importe quel journal à scandale est
ailleurs journal que le monde c'est
évidemment faux hélas fini de rigoler
jacques je crois que c'est une fonction
pause cherche
hélas hélas fini ligne hot ça va
s'arrêter et l'infini de rigoler
pourquoi pourquoi
pour toi fini de rigoler sur une chaîne
commerciale
il suffit pas de faire beaucoup
d'audience une part de marché encore
faut-il que l'audience correspondent à
la suivrai publicitaire que tu veux
toucher en l'occurrence la sainte la
célèbre ménagères de moins de cinquante
ans que tu l'appelles dans le privé
vient sorcières c'est quoi ça c'est très
simple voilà quand on entend à la radio
par exemple
exemple chez morandini sur europe 1 tous
les matins vers 10h30 j'entends voici
les scores de la veille a également
alors intel a fait 30 % de parts de
marché et 3 millions de téléspectateurs
lors il faut expliquer ce que c'est les
gens combien de rien à ça c'est très
simple quand vous faites 30% de parts de
marché ou un peu plus c'est le cas de ce
que fait tirer régulièrement japonais de
cheval et la télé comment s'appelle
raconte michel les gens n'ont jamais vu
ça crois que c'est la première et a
demandé la permission à médiamétrie
j'imagine à jacqueline aglietta
voilà c'est dit c'est un très bon alors
voilà ce qui se passe 30% de parts de
marché ça veut dire que sur 100
téléspectateurs
il y en a trente qui vous ont regardé et
ça représente combien ça quel public
là ça représente peut-être cinq six sept
ou huit points 1 point d'audience
correspond à 530 mille téléspectateurs à
l'aja quand par exemple syrie fait 4
points d'audience
il fait deux millions et demi
téléspectateurs quand il fait 30 %
d'audience ça veut dire qu'à cette
heure-là il ya trente spectateurs sur
100 qui le regardait la télé accord pour
dire que l'on en perles
non je crois pas ok on verra on verra la
cour à caen mais mais mais on peut faire
sans une télévision de masse 5 millions
de téléspectateurs et 40% le marché qui
est une fausse bonne audience
elles touchent pas la cible qu'on veut
toucher la fameuse ménagère heureusement
dans le service public on peut encore
montrer aux gens ce qu'ils aiment et ce
qu'ils pourraient mes maîtres de la
culture ses sensations et toujours là tu
me rend vraiment justice en disant que
champs elysées était pourtant
d'émissions culturelles y en a très vite
voilà maintenant j là j'ai pris une
évidemment mon émission parce que les
bras l'école découvre des autres je
connais pas les coupes les regarder
dimanche 26 après midi regardez serge
khalfon sais pas si tu peut cadrer là il
ya tous les quarts d'heure là vous avez
367.72 points multipliés 7 points par
cinq
ça fait 3 millions et 4 millions et
l'accueil en héros et vous avez 32
on avait fait un carton jour là ça veut
dire que 30 de téléspectateurs sur 110
vaches séverine de regarder ce matin
c'est pas tout une fois que vous avez ça
arrive
la courbe par exemple ça le soir la cour
mais j'ai mes notes électro cardiogramme
notes électro encéphalogrammes oui ça je
peux vous dire
à 9h15 quand tombe la comme tu me diras
pas le concubin le dimanche matin au
lieu des phrases voilà ça s'est vivement
dimanche de pierre dont dix à quinze
jours chez les dinos regarder la 4
points d'audience aviron commence à deux
millions de spectateurs parce que la pub
c'est pas toujours un avantage pour
démarrer on monte on monte on monte on
monte et vous arrivez là ça fait douze
points
minute par minute ça veut dire que ça ça
veut dire que là certains d'entre vous
sont allés soulager leur vessie et puis
sont venues d'autres un petit peu zappé
mais c'est pas tout ça c'est l'après
midi voyez tout un tac tac tac tac
savary 1.2 points c'est assez
vertigineux musclé plus vertigineux
c'est qu'à 11 heures
vous avez les cibles que vous êtes
structure d'audience à préserver les
moins de 50 ans les plus de 50 ans les
masses à la fameuse ménager tout
possible et ça c'est extrêmement fiable
pourquoi parce que de cette courbe de
cette mesure statistique dépend le tarif
unitaire
ils n'ont pas intérêt à se louper et
d'ailleurs toutes les chaînes soient
abonnés médiamétrie et j'en terminerai
et s'en servir pour vous dire que si un
jour on vient vous demander chez vous si
vous pouvez faire voulais faire partie
du panel passe comment ça fonctionne ça
y'a 8500 personnes en france qui pendant
plusieurs années appartiennent au panel
ça représente trois mille sept cents
foyers pour toute la france toute
profession représentation moyenne de la
france petites mains d'entreprises
villes des grandes agglomérations
chaleur tous bords et sur la non non
vous avez chez vous personne
on vous met un bain
un petit ordinateur qui correspond à une
télécommande 6,6 à trois postes chez
vous si vos enfants
regarde un dessin animé sur l'a6 et
qu'ils appuient s'est enregistrée dans
l'ordinateur la nuit qui dépouillent
tous à levallois perret si vos grands
parents sont dans le salon regarde
tyrannie sont ils le savent on dépouille
tout ça est à 9h15 le matin et vous avez
ça et souvent vous passé une mauvaise
journée et je dirais pour conclure et je
dirais bonne chance aux jeunes qui
démarrent maintenant des jeunes
justement qui vit aujourd'hui la la télé
c'est des concepts acheter à l'étranger
présenté par des animateurs
interchangeables c'est la vérité la
différence tient dans le service public
qui fête ses 40 ans lundi et est
regardée de la mieux comprendre ce que j
en gravant l'émission c'est que la
différence entre le service public pour
moi et france 2 il s'agit de france 2 et
des chaînes commerciales en général et
pas seulement en france à l'étranger
c'est qu'il ya un attachement du public
très fort pour une chaîne publique où on
retrouve des animateurs qui comme moi
sont là depuis très longtemps
les animateurs services publics sont
pratiquement aussi alors que le concept
qu'il présente moi les autres sont des
balles très bien mais si ses choix
jacques si c'est pas lui qui présente
tout le monde en parle tu regardes pas
non si c'est pas pivot qui aura besoin
je regarde pas si c'est parce oeuvrant
je regarde pas et si c'est par la suite
de la rue qui prend sa dilution notre
émission sevran martin pivot chancel toi
moi on n'est plus des gamins on a tous
plus de 50 la merde moi à tanger nord
gagne pas dans la synthèse je ne sais
pas finie recherche de place dans la
catégorie des meilleurs chroniqueurs de
la télé chroniqueur enfin c'est bien
finir à tous mes chroniqueurs jean
wiener chroniqueurs
annick et alors eh bien ça pour dire que
les animateurs du service public pourra
aussi fort que le concept qu'il présente
je leur le noyau ta dépendance à la
cocaïne
je sais très bien non plus bien que
j'arrêtais depuis longtemps leur mue par
mauvais souvenirs documents que je n'ai
pas apporté la fin j'ai un document à la
télé j'ai bu tamer el mahdi elle n'a pas
joué ouais alors à la télé il ya il ya
beaucoup d'argent et tu as été toi
soumis à la pression de l'argent à
l'époque quand berlusconi ta ta ta
invités pour aller à ce moment là sur la
500 a dit vous possédez quoi monsieur
drucker et tu lui as dit rien oui il est
dit que j'avais fait gagner des
montagnes d'argent mais francis ben
ouais mais qu'est ce que vous possédez
approche à l'égard d'un idiot gib.a vous
savez bon j'ai une voiture comme tout le
monde j'ai un appartement que je payer à
crédit à l'époque j'ai une maison à la
campagne petite maison j'espère un jour
d'avoir une plus grande au soleil j'ai
pas de dettes je paye mes impôts et je
suis très content comme ça il m'a
regardé il me dit et c'est tout ce que
vous possédez un après trente ans de
télé mais bien le scanner francine gagné
mais berlusconi lui il te disais ça vous
tente pas une ferrari
votre femme aime pas les mandats c'est
ce qui m'a dit berlusconi
je vais en italie le voir il voulait
m'engager pour être conseillé de la
chaîne et l'animateur vitrine
ouais il survient avec un contrat
l'incident et le dîner chez ma mère si
je peux pas dire ça ma mère je veux dire
qu'on propose ça puis j'arrive
mon pauvre argent venait d'être nommé
patron de france 2 il est resté un an et
il me dit coup de voilà je suis un de
mes façons de france 2 j'avais arrêté
champs elysées car j'étais crevé une il
faut que tu reprennes j'appelle
berlusconi non je lui dit silvio se
tutoyaient déjà je peux pas venir chez
toi il dit c'est pas assez payés jc par
le problème c'est des milliards qu'ils
me proposent mais les italiens d'un sens
de la famille mon frère vient d'être
nommé patron de france 2 je vais l'aider
et c'est ce qui vient mais j'achète mon
frère aussi
alors du ciel on vous reproche souvent
d'être d'être trop gentil
oui vous le savez trop complaisant trop
complaisant alors là j'ai pris une
petite liste de gens sur lesquels je
vais vous demander d'être méchant ou guy
bedos à guy bedos est informée je peux
pas dire du mal de gi joes et
réconcilier tous les guides d'un faux
méchant saint-yves extrêmement entendre
mais un truc méchants très méchants
intrigue méchant c'est tout ils se
trouvent sur pierre palmade johnny un
truc mais chanson johnny hallyday a
c'est absolument impossible si jenny un
truc très méchants très méchants très
méchants sur un truc il reste du mal
la prochaine fois que j'arrive chez toi
comme souvent le dimanche matin en vélo
et qu'ils me traitent de blaireaux avec
mon casque je te fout un coup de boule
ouais un truc les champs sur bernadette
chirac bernadette chirac pourrait donner
des leçons de générosité à bien des
femmes de gauche comme j'ai dis un truc
méchant michel rolland méchant je suis
pas toujours d'accord sur ces chapeaux
moi j'suis assez de son qui m'avait dit
un truc mes chances urbain fini tient au
baffie mais laurence et c'est très
compliqué dire du mal de laurent parce
que parce que je
il faudrait formidable il faut faire je
le connais il faudrait pas que je
connaisse dans la vie et tu le connais
c'est un père de famille très attentive
je suis sûr que c'est un bon père de
famille c'est comme toi il ya des gens
qui me disent votre ami ardisson celle
d'une vache chaque soir mais jeudi
mettant des si vous saviez comme
séparent bons plans un bon père de
famille et un bon mari que je t'ai dis
une chose je donne raison
tim est dit un jour c'était quand on
était sur les plages du débarquement
finalement tu as raison il n'y a pas de
honte à être bienveillant tu sais que je
me suis drucké risée mois avec la mairie
non mais thiery
alors mon problème à moi c'est un non
sens gentille et emmenés en quarante ans
j'ai dû me suis fait tellement de
copains même sont pas allemands des amis
on se connaît trop moi j'ai reçu jacques
souvent johnny sait pas combien
hasardeux et bien je les connais trop on
finit par avoir et toi aussi
ça fait combien ses 7 ans alors tu fais
la télé depuis combien 20 ans moi je
vois bien quand je te regarde le samedi
soir je commence à bien connaître
il lui aussi ayant fini par être par un
gendarme en métro qu'en richelle que tu
n'as tu n'as pas d'amis dans ce métier
non j'ai des amis très proches de moi
mais comme j'ai pas eu de vrai coup dur
qui ont remis ma vie en question j'ai
pas eu le temps de les compter le jour
j'aurai vraiment viré de la télévision
non mais je peux avoir c'est tant que
c'était tu l'as pas toi tu vas nous
faire chier jusqu'à 90 fallait avec ça
bon je vais te la jeune carrément dû par
oui mais alors tout droit s'ils désirent
est ce que tu sais qu' il y aura dans
les 15 ans qui viennent
9000 centenaires en france tu rentres à
partir là et que dans l'est et que
écouta et que dans les dix ans qui
viennent 10 ans et demain 50% de la
population française aura plus de 50 ans
a en effet déménagé reader wi et dans
les 15 ans qui viennent il y aura plus
de gens de 60 ans que de gens de moins
de 20 ans comme messieurs les carrières
pour messieurs les publicitaires à midi
et on est tranquille quoi tes peinard
pour 20 ans voilà c'est tout
surtout tu bois d'auch tu fume pas qui
fait des abdominaux tu te couches tôt
l'asa souvent c'est trop
bien